[Music]
ken we need to talk about this uh
employment situation you're the expert
on this
and um
i'm an expert on my opinion so we got a
really good opportunity here to talk
about this
but um
there is some weird
economic data
that the media is not parsing through
and it is telling a dif that is telling
a different story of reality than the
politicians on either side
want you to believe okay so side one is
uh that
you know we're at the best
job market
in the history of the world there's a
shortage of workers
we can't get enough workers i can't fill
the jobs that we have available at
ramsey
okay which is true by the way probably
got a hundred positions we could fill
today roughly we can't get so there's
for you know there's at arguably full
employment
anybody that really wants to work in
this current economy is working
is able to work is working
from an economic perspective
um and so
the current administration would say
look at us look at this great economy
although we know we're in a recession
we know that the fed thinks we're in a
horrible
inflationary situation so they're going
to slam
interest rates up and and what they said
so that they can cause some pain that's
correct that's exactly what the [ __ ] at
the fed actually said we want to cause
some pain we want some more unemployment
and we want things to slow down well
thank you very much
you
aristocracy piece of trash
oh my god yeah the first thing we want
to do is not let the little people
prosper if we're in the fed so i already
trashed on him last week so i'll just
hold that for now yeah hold that thought
but anyway so we've got this side that
the economy is in such good shape that
it's inflating
and the market place is full and you're
yet
and there's a shortage of workers
and yet
we find people looking for work every
day there seems to be a shortage of
quote good jobs so what we're really
finding when you dug into the data you
were showing me this earlier is that
it's not um it's not as easy as saying
jobs that's correct it's what jobs
that's right there are more options the
way to look at it is there's more
options available now to people than
previously existed that that are
attracted to them so example where we
see less jobs give you one really
dumpster fire situation we have 300 000
less teachers now than we did prior to
the pandemic 300 000 less teachers how
many less police we've got that's
correct you're seeing a lot of
municipalities with jobs so local
government state government jobs aren't
as attractive as they used to be and and
there's a reason for this this is upward
mobility and i think a lot of people are
like well it was always safe but it's
always been pretty stagnant so there's
more opportunities for people you're
seeing people move into delivery jobs
you're seeing people moving to
warehouses but environment the
environment of those jobs the culture
what it feels like to be a cop today or
feels like to be a teacher today is way
different than five years ago there's no
question about that we actually saw this
recently just about a month or so ago
you can look it up for yourself uh the
fraternal order of police had their
meeting in washington dc the national
chairman of the sheriff's they came out
and said we're losing good people and
they're moving into a different sector
of the society do the same type of
protecting work so a lot of private
security things of that nature because
they don't want to be treated this way
they don't want to feel unsafe so what's
happening is we've just seen a big
reshuffling of the chairs and so what
happens is when you hear things like
well there's a job gap well that that's
a function of there are one and a half
jobs
available for every person that's
unemployed in the united states you see
a lot of people choose retirement not
come back out so we've got this big gap
and so when you see a gap like that what
you see is companies are competing
everything from a kid making 16 an hour
at target that's real 20. yeah but i'm
talking about a 16 year old kid i got a
friend of mine who just got that job and
so what happens is is that you see
inflationary pressures from wages
so now the fed's going well we've got a
good inflation under control and what
they're trying to do to get inflation
under control is drive up unemployment
the august job numbers were out we're at
3.7 percent unemployment we were 3.6 in
july
so they're actively trying to drive
unemployment up hoping that that will
cool type of unemployment that goes up
is going to be those century entry
levels that's correct so it's not going
to actually solve the inflationary
process it's not going to solve the
nursing shortage or a cop shortage it's
not going to solve uh you know
dev2s
developers no software engineers private
sector is
that's right it's only picking on the
little guy that's why i was talking
about the the arrogance of the
aristocracy because they are looking at
a number as a jobs number holistically
rather than saying all right let's parse
this and go okay
by the way uber eats is way up well what
does that really mean
well i'll tell you what that actually
means when uber eats goes up it your
prices go up so your 18 pizza is now 22
your combo meal
so that's what's really cool i mean what
what's that guy doing what would he what
would he have been doing with his life
if he wasn't doing a breach well he's
probably in another hourly wage position
and so he's going it's a side hustle
that's exactly right are they counting
the side hustles as
as full employment no they do not so
part-time jobs
are in a separate category in the jobs
report so the unemployment is it's
really where someone's choosing to be
unemployed meaning so they're not
working a full-time job part-time really
doesn't count doesn't weigh into that
okay so if you're a professional in
a b or c position
that makes um 80 to 150
okay um there is a uh
you've got your choice right now
right now you do
right now you do if jerome powell and
the fed has their way it could really
squeeze that we could see and he's
predicting fourth quarter layoffs first
quarter of 2023 layoffs 150 000 is not
at the front line of the layoffs
uh not at the front line but you're also
seeing like larger companies will
because they get concerned about the
economy you could see those people get
laid off and now you're gonna have
another rush for that position so
facebook and google and um
one other one i was trying to remember
who was in the article came out and said
uh believe it was apple if they don't
have an increase in productivity they
basically threatened their team
that if you don't have an increase in
productivity that um we're uh gonna have
to do layoffs yes uh and yet the vast
majority of their people are working
from home and then turn around tim cook
says at apple uh he says to his
employees get this please
come back to the office oh yeah well
exactly that's different than ramsey oh
yeah we kind of just said come back to
the office voluntold i like that word
you can yeah you were we've told you
you're going to voluntold yourself back
to the office because this is where we
were right well so you know what that
speaks to two things number one tim cook
is weak
just being honest number one he runs the
largest company in the world yeah but
he's weak when he says that yeah but
he's afraid of his employees
there's the leverage issue yeah if those
highly skilled workers leave to go
somewhere else it's a lot harder to find
them in the sense of getting them in for
the same pace so he's trying to save
money by placating the workforce so i'm
not trying to take a shot at his
character i'm saying from a little bit
he called him weak yeah well yeah
hello pot i'm kettle uh i mean he that's
a weak leadership move it really is you
can't plead
and bargain with your employees what you
have to do is just make it appealing for
them to come in or you put a clear
directive out there says if you don't
come in
you don't work here and we've seen
companies try that elon musk did he said
you know you can not work from home
somewhere correct
interesting times right now the the
chairs have shifted a good bit it's a
very it's a weird i think it may be the
weirdest job market i've seen in 30 or
40. that is correct the most unique for
a very very strange job market
vote for both sides the hiring and the
hired